à Naples
mijangos extinction des troupeaux de la
riche de notre travail doit faire partie
de cette merde dans la diversité regarde le
la richesse qui existe ici du
différents pays est la conviction
que nous voulons une vie meilleure
trois entreprises et des gens d'argent
ils allaient à Jackson Heights ont
être de purs boricuas notre peuple
dans notre histoire mais un peu et
il y a des changements maintenant si vous en voulez un autre mais
autre société
parce que je ne sais pas qu'ils sont unis et qu'ils se rassemblent
parce que rien d'autre ne se plaint ou diane par
miséricorde je te demande
et médicaments
déteste je veux plus d'indifférence parce que le
la rancune a moins que j'oublie si tu
ils me détestent
avec lui
de l'expérience
En cela